boulet cav show special guest pulled up
with the grand marnier
mickey facts mickey what up man
yo i don't think enough people in
hip-hop know about grand marnier because
you're the only rapper i've ever seen
off that grand marnier man yeah yeah
that's the way it's supposed to be
that's that orange [ __ ] yeah the cool is
this something like this is like your
go-to
it's been my go-to as of late um i was
heavy on it in 09 when i did my deal at
jive and i just started picking it back
up recently
all right so
i always when i think of mickey facts i
think of golden era of
the blog era of rap music yeah yeah at
the time there was not right there's two
dope boys all these just
staples and you know really the real
anr's of that era were those blog sites
right yep um and you were one of the
forefathers of that era
i feel like you know you kind of you
know
grandfathered a lot of that [ __ ] that
was going on at that time man and um you
know obviously was on the second
freshman cover yep the one that really
made the freshman cover like blow a
thing
because that first freshman cover was
cool it was cool great artist on there
but it wasn't like really a thing until
the second one hit second one hit it
changed the game
um because the first one as as great as
i thought it was a great cover
but it didn't do too well it was like
crooked eye joel ortiz lupe lupe was
boozy on there lucy was on it yeah
um
saigon yep pap it was a couple people on
it the thing about it was like the game
was changing from the streets to the to
the internet
and when dayton thomas got there he was
like i want to do a freshman cover and i
want to cover the blog the people who
was big on the blogs
they said hell no
and he was he fought and fought and
fought and made it happen because the
last one didn't sell well when we did
that one that's like the top
selling that was one of the top selling
magazines yeah cause it was you asher
roth wale b.o.b b.o.b charles hamilton
corey cory guns
every time i hear charles hamilton's
name i just i have a such a big fan
free charles he's locked up right now oh
is he [ __ ] yeah cory guns was ace hood
on there they said cudi cudi currency
wow and blue
wow yeah that's a crazy cover that's a
crazy cover it's nuts and it's funny too
because at the time
i remember like the the the people who
you were like
hmm it was like ace hood ace had made
the cover and i was like
hmm i mean obviously ace went on to have
hit records in like a great career and
stuff but like incredible but you know
it was such a it was it to me it just
kind of really
time stamped the era
perfectly perfectly it was a perfect
perfect perfectly balanced like thanos
would say we were you know was there a
lot of camaraderie between a lot of a
lot of you guys on that cover at the
time the time me and corey were very
cool uh
i was a fan of blue me and currency was
super cool
uh me and wale had a little bit of
issues
uh me and cuddy had did a record we were
cool me and co uh me and charles were
cool i had met ace hood that day
so for the most part i was cool with
everybody though what was that what were
the issues you had with wale
it was just some music stuff like i was
trying to get some music done with him
um
me him and push i was trying to get a
track with us three on it and it just
didn't happen
um so i kind of took offense to that i
was new to the game so i didn't really
understand what was going on i didn't
know how i thought if somebody sent you
a record and you know you guys on the
same level you're coming up you just get
it done but
uh he he was real busy at the time he
couldn't get to it so that was like one
of my first lessons in the industry but
i took it to heart and that's why we
kind of had issues at that time was that
an awkward shoot
it was a very awkward shoot it's very
awkward
um but you know
there was you know darker forces behind
the scenes and
when he kind of realized what was going
on he kind of spun the block and was
like you're my fault you know
um i understand what you was trying to
do and there was people that was in my
ear at the time so you know he
apologized and we kind of got behind it
after that yeah it's crazy because if
you look at a lot of the guys on that
cover right there's so much like
what ifs on that cover right yeah what
if asher roth came out five years later
because i feel like asher roth missed
kind of the window to be like
i guess what jack harlow is now or with
g eazy and mac like you know what i mean
i think when asher roth came out i don't
think people really got it all the way i
think all of us i think
when you look at that cover all of us
were the guinea pigs for every other
artist that came out after
um
you know from you you take someone like
you take someone like asha like you said
you know people saw that and then you
have mac miller afterwards
um you you look at somebody like blue
you see that and then you know after
blue you have like a fachon or you have
a j cole right um currency right like
currency was just incredible after that
you know you get which ways
um so like people saw what the mistakes
that we may have made and just kind of
was like okay i'm gonna stay away from
that and and kind of do this or i'm
gonna do this or i'm gonna work with
these guys that came out before us and
what about for you what do you think
like for you
maybe you know
were the things that transpired that
maybe kind of prevented you from meeting
your fullest potential because you had
full you know full record deals and all
that [ __ ] like
two main things with people taking my
style being a little bit more popular
than me at the time
um i was the guy doing skinny jeans i
was the guy who was fashion forward i
was the guy putting a song out every
week on the internet when nobody was
doing it yeah you did that
it was either you were crooked eye
crooked i did the freestyles
shout out to crooked eye he did the
freestyles every week
i was putting out songs like i put drake
drake was on that series
when nobody knew who drake was cuddy was
on that series um
you know corey was on that series like
i was when i was doing that it was it
felt different buckshot was on that it
was just a whole bunch of craziness so i
think that mixed with the fashion people
kind of took the skinny jeans because
people were baggy like if you oh for
sure people were crazy looking at the
time so so those two things and then
jive folding
when jai folded that was the end that
was the that was the end of my
trajectory because
now i'm moving on to rca i did a deal
with rca because i didn't get dropped
it's just a label folded so
p the people did get dropped but i had
got another deal it's the same me and
justin timberlake on the same label so
he got moved to rca or epic and i got
moved to rca did a new deal but it's
people who didn't believe in me and
understand yeah the same people who we a
r's the people who brought you on a team
they're no longer there they're no
longer there and when you're like that
in a re in a building it's like you're
in no man's land it's no man's land so
that's what happened and that's the
reason why i kind of just
fell apart it happens a lot right
especially it doesn't even happen when
the label folds it happens when someone
gets fired yep
then you get somebody who doesn't know
the president comes in they didn't
assign you they don't believe in you
they just following the numbers the
analytics so that's kind of what
happened to me in that space and you
know stuff like that has happened to a
lot of artists yeah for sure and they
and a lot of them haven't recovered uh
xv you know xv somebody who simon warner
and
just they didn't know what the [ __ ] to
do with him and he was an alien like xb
was like kendrick lamar level talent
insane insane huge support system fan
base but like you said once you get into
that system their move they were still
moving by the archaic rules you know get
a radio record do some promo whereas the
internet was just coming along spotify
hadn't started yet spotify and it was
soundcloud was around that time when he
got his deal so like things you know the
labels didn't know what to do the blogs
were in charge at the time so it was
tough for them to figure out how to make
money off of a world whereas post
napster
presently z share and hulk share
mediafire mediafire
and then we're right before soundcloud
spotify apple music and things like that
you know it's crazy because like like
when you think about that cover is like
you know so like i was a huge charleston
i mean i was a huge fan of b.o.b b.o.b
obviously went on to have hit records
and hit records but but it also took a
while yeah it took him two years yeah
you know like even i even think about
like coal like coal was the year after
or two years later coal was the year
after he was on the 2010 cover i think
of like even coal like they didn't know
what to do with coal forever he popped
in 2012. yeah like it was like bro like
it was a weird error for the industry
because like you said like it's like how
do you monetize this internet buzz
if there isn't a hit record because of
the labels now as long as it streams it
doesn't matter if he's playing on the
radio
it took them 10 years to figure it out
yeah because napster pops up o2
03
and you know then you have uh whatever
else
uh streaming sites that was out around
that time i forgot what the other ones
were but then and then it just kept
moving moving forward moving forward
youtube 05 you know myspace
um
twitter everything just started so
the labels were confused you know when i
first joined twitter nobody was on
twitter right there was no labels on
twitter there was no news sites on
twitter there was nobody on twitter so
once they started to get the hang of it
then they started to put their minds
together it was like we're gonna we're
gonna take over by doing this doing this
doing that and now this the streaming
services
it's back to the way it was they're in
control again yeah it's almost like carl
cherry's like the new sk
kind of right
or like you know because you would think
like i mean i saw with my own eyes like
if you could get shake or mech to post
your [ __ ] on two dope boys
it literally like will change your life
life changing yeah if sk posted you
forget about it over like at that in the
real like early stages not right was the
blog
period it was not right and then you
know everyone else was coming up and not
right was like the standards like if if
you got on alright it was like oh [ __ ]
this i got it i listen to everything on
that right i was on that right three
times a week
that's crazy
[Laughter]
every week for the year i was only three
times a week yeah i mean yeah
i missed the era of music because it did
feel like those guys had like legitimate
love for
quality and
i think that
the blog era at least the gatekeepers
in my opinion were the best
gatekeepers we've ever had because they
were the most tuned in and they you know
like i'm real
over the years was really tight with
shake and mac and those guys and like
they like genuinely like if they didn't
like your music they didn't post it yeah
and that was that's different right
because now
you're gonna get on a playlist because
it's an algorithm or because like you
know
even if the song sucks if you're the
bigger name or you got you're on a label
you're getting on rap caviar even if
someone who's running that playlist is
like this [ __ ] is ass
as to where back then i feel like at
least the gatekeepers were like
hip-hop nerds
and they wrote about it it was over and
they had a post where they typed and it
was like yo like they took pride in like
help building people's careers like yeah
oh my i owe my career to now right and
all of the blogs on smash two boys even
world star hip-hop you know star yeah
they when they first were starting out
you know they were underneath not right
and then you know the fights helped them
but a lot of times it was the music my
freestyles that would go up there it
would help build up the site you know so
you know a lot of these places was just
starting out even hip hop dx all hip-hop
they were just starting out do you
remember the forum days before the blogs
hip-hop game hip-hop game
there was a realist n words.com i used
to download all my mixtapes off of uh
slums of boxton
oh my gosh you know back then jay
electronica he would post links and then
delete them oh really he would go into
these chat rooms into these forums post
a link to like act one or act two and
then delete it that's crazy
yeah those those uh those those that's
how i got my name
i would illegally download mixtapes and
albums from those forums
and then go to the swap meet when i was
16 and slang them [ __ ] wow yeah
i used to sell mixtapes in in bootleg
albums when i was in high school that's
crazy hey what up man we got to
interrupt the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at odd socks
now when i be riding for odd socks so
hard man it's because i really love the
product they got the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world i got a pair
of odd socks basics on right now go get
those they got the socks wwe joints you
know i'm saying shout out to the
undertaker pepsi [ __ ] really
whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview i just think like now it's
kind of it's kind of like somewhere in
the middle unfortunately like
you know like there's not as many
gatekeepers right there's only a few
yeah and you know i mean i i consider
carl cherry a gatekeeper yeah and carl's
super tuned in he's super he is a
hip-hop fanatic you know like carl's he
was a part of the double xl freshman
cover yeah carl's a [ __ ]
one of the good guys i say you know um
and carl's taking chances on a lot of
artists too like there's a kid out of la
named nana that's incredible that like
doesn't even have 10 000 followers but
he's a [ __ ] incredible artist grip
who just signed with shady grip that's
my boy i love grip you know i found out
about grip i had a show in nebraska and
the promoter he just kept playing grip
and i'm like who is this guy this guy
was incredible so yes guy named grip man
he's dope i dm'd grip immediately he's
fired i didn't even know he was signing
he got an album called snub nose from
2019 that's fire i think that was the
album i was listening to he is
incredible and you know i hit him up
like yo man i think you're dope would
love to work month later sinus shady wow
um
kind of break down the fake uh internet
altercations obviously you and luke are
real close right like yeah that's my bro
you guys like we're kind of trolling
each other for a while i don't know i
don't know if he was trolling each other
i think it was one of those things we
was just kind of uh having conversations
about hip-hop you know just trying to
you know there was this talk about who's
the best and you know i was just trying
to conduct the interview i wasn't i
actually think lupe fiasco like
lyrically
as like a just pure rapper he's he might
be like top five to 10 ever i'm not
talking about like
and by the way he's got
classic projects yes but like if we're
just talking about putting you in a room
here's a pad of paper
go crazy i'm not sure there's many
people in the history of this planet
that can hang with lupe fiasco
i say that with all due respect i agree
i agree he's one of he's one of the
greats he's my biggest what if yeah like
lupe to me should be on the like like
when i think of like lupe's trajectory
and like how atlanta kind of stalled i
feel like atlantic stalled him out and i
feel like at some point in time he might
have maybe just lost not not necessarily
lost passion for the hip-hop
like as art form but just for the
industry yeah i mean i think
i just think he wanted to do what he
wanted to do
and i think atlantic saw the success of
superstar right you're like we need more
of that we need more of that and he's
like bro i'm an artist i want to do this
and then lasers comes out and it's like
shout out to my guy pooh bear you know
but at the time it was going by mdma but
like there's like a lot of these like
commercial like like weird r b hooks
that just didn't feel right we're just
like yo that's not why we came here in
the first place that's not why lupe's
got a [ __ ] cult following they're not
here for that [ __ ]
yeah i mean they gave him his biggest
records though i think you know no he
did i mean obviously yeah like you said
uh the record trey was huge tray record
was
nuts
and even you know the show goes on
but you know he's still top five tops
man listen i was i don't know was it
2015 that murals uh the song murals came
out he was rapping for nine minutes
straight and it was just and i just
remember like saying that anybody who
thinks lupe fell off just press play on
that girls and it's like what the [ __ ]
that smithsonian rap right there yes
it's crazy man but uh you have a joint
project out with blue yeah that's my
brother shout out to blue somebody else
you know his album that first album with
exile was another moment like in like
below the heavens is a backpack
you know moment it was like
a moment in backpack history yeah like
that boom bap like wow [ __ ] like he was
right i want to say he was right before
the blog era and because that dropped in
oh seven
so he was right before yeah cause it
came out when i was in high school yeah
and that project is i'm a fan of that
project yeah so you guys originally met
at the cover shoot
we actually met we had a show together
at rock the bells was it rock the bells
no it was uh the brooklyn hip-hop fest
we had a show together
and uh that's what we first met and then
we met again at the cover
so you guys have obviously kept rapport
throughout the years and now you know
what was this what was the uh
whose idea was it to do a project
together it was mine we were on tour in
2018 and i was like yo i think we should
do a project while we were in the car
and he was like
yup
let's do it and i was like all right so
i went you know we both was reaching out
to different producers to see who could
do the whole thing and um we we settled
on knotts
knots is a legend and knots was like
yeah let's do it so you know we just
kind of went and and picked beats and we
put this project together it was great
it's crazy it's called the narrative how
is it uh
because you know when you you're working
on solo [ __ ] you really only have to
worry about
like your vision right it's it's it's
not you know you know what your
perspective is
you know how to get your point across
how
is the dynamic changing when you have
when you bring a whole another prolific
rapper to the table and you guys have to
collaborate on like these things for the
most part i'm a pretty easygoing mc if
he a lot of times blue would have
concepts and i'd be like okay and i'll
just run with it and there were times
when you know i would put i put like
maybe two of them two of the songs
together and he was like okay cool
i mean once you have two people that
don't have big egos that come together
they're both just trying to make sure
that the project just comes together
pretty well it was a very easy project
for us to put together it took forever
to come out because of the features we
were waiting a long time for the
features to come who was on the album we
got code of a friend shout out to coda
uh we got a tank uh uh taviana bell from
taking the bangers we have sorry the kid
on there he's dope asher roth is on
there shout out to asher um fishon is on
there oswent benjamin ozwin is my guy i
love ozzy my producer tony chalk and him
are doing a whole project together
yeah
it's funny because he was going to do a
he was going to do uh
high on life
um freestyle i listen so he calls me
while i'm in new york and he's like yo
mickey i got to do a higher life
freestyle
and i was like
i got to do a bootleg cab freestyle but
i haven't written anything yet
and he was like
i'm about to get on the flight i said i
when you land
my verse would be done
so when he landed i called him verse was
done and we both split our verses and he
was like yo tell blue guy kevin i sell
what's up cause he's he's he's on my
bucket list like no he's coming up here
yeah he was like yo he's on my bucket
list i said yeah kev was on my bucket
list he lives in my hometown he's in
he's in phoenix now yeah he's in my
hometown yeah yeah ozman's uh gonna
gonna have a nice career he's incredible
he could do a lot he could sing he could
rap he's he's he's very i mean i i don't
think like he's had the moment where we
can say he slept on yet
but
you know i think he's bubbling and when
his moment comes it'll be soon it'll be
big it's gonna it's it's on the way i
believe it's on the way i think he you
know he just has to you know figure it
out once he figures it out he's out of
here yeah he's got a lot of talent uh
yeah that's dope uh so with with this
album do you feel like um
you know cause i i do feel like
was there a point in time where you kind
of just stepped away from music yeah i
quit music in 2013 at the end of 2013.
and was that like a hard thing for you
to do man because i know you know i know
this industry will spit you up chew you
up and spit you out man it was too much
that was going on
you know
i left rca
it just wasn't it's a shitty label
unless you're a priority shout out to
rca but god bless them but yeah if
you're not a priority [ __ ] they had d1
on rca forever and they know what the
[ __ ] to do anyway i digress i left and
then i lost a lot of money in 2013 not
working
and i had 414 in my bank account and i
was like man i'm not doing rap no more
and then 2014 comes around and i'm like
i couldn't get a job
because i hadn't have i hadn't worked
since 2007.
so by april
when i realized that i couldn't get a
job i was like well time to rap again
and that just kind of was my resurgence
and i went into my plan b which was just
being this emcee that can just that just
goes to just raps and people just kind
of you know it just continued to
snowball snowball snowball snowball
snowball
and now you know i am i'm here you know
yeah i think what's dope is like now
uh there is no middleman if you want to
drop music you just get a distrokit
account
and you're on and you're wrong and you
can run up your indie catalog and even
if you have
a thousand fans that are your core fan
base there's a way to monetize that and
and make a living off of this rap [ __ ]
yep you just tell everybody like you got
to be consistent and you have to like
figure out how to get to a point where
you have enough fans that are like die
hard fans it could be 500 kids
and if they support everything you do
and you're strategic and you're smart
you're going to be able to pay your
bills off rap music
you know what i'm saying
you turn 500 into 600 and so on and so
forth and i think that's what's kind of
been dope about like uh
somebody like you know
what griselda's done is like they've
just racked up so much catalog
and russ who took a page out of your
book shout out to russ russ you know did
a one song a week for a year
but it's like just betting on yourself
knowing guess what not every record is
going to be a hit
no it doesn't work like that but it's
okay
because every record someone's going to
listen to it and it just communicates it
all adds up like it all builds up it all
adds up and i think that's what matters
right like being able to
you know put out content that your
supporters really appreciate
and they want to support you because
they feel like you're giving them the
soundtrack to not only your life but
their life and that matters to them a
lot so you know and also put you in a
dope creative position because now
you're just giving people what they want
not what the people on the 52nd floor
wants right because they're all about
numbers and analytics like nah you guys
i'm mickey facts people [ __ ] with me
because i can wrap my [ __ ] ass off
right so let me give y'all some of that
that's why that's how i got here that's
how i got here and that's how we're
gonna stay here yeah straight up man
well look uh the album is out go support
it the narrative me blue knots make sure
you guys go pick that up it's crazy yo
go support shout out to knott's legend
he's from virginia right virginia beach
man i don't know what's in the water he
did a whole album with asher roth i
believe that and [ __ ] crazy yeah yeah
he's incredible yo shout out to virginia
for producing
pharrell timberland
and knotts
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] wow i didn't know [ __ ]
was from virginia he's from virginia
something about something in the water
in virginia for producers boy
is is missy from there yeah
is she from virginia i don't know if
missy's from virginia i mean she thinks
she is she might be
we we're checking that is it is magoo
from virginia i don't know
hey the first uh tim elena magu album
finally is on dsp shout out to empire uh
crazy [ __ ] she's a producer to the
eclipse
[Laughter]
the clips chad hugo we can't we don't
get enough give enough love to chat chat
is man monster monster all right well
look uh there's gonna be another youtube
video where this guy's
dude look rapping his ass off blacking
out let's go yes sir